So, as we decided in an earlier quiz, we're going to divide the search engine
code into two modules. One corresponds to the things that we do before, one of
which is about building the corpus, this is all the things that we can do before
a search query comes in. Another one is the code for all the things that we do
after a query. I'm going to give those names. We'll call the first module,
crawler, since what is does is crawls the web and builds a corpus. This also
includes the page ranking which we might think could be a separate module.
That's something we can do after we finish the crawl. For now, we'll keep that
in the crawler module. And we'll call the other module search.py. Once we've
divided code into modules like this, well, we shouldn't need to worry about all
these details anymore. So, for now, we're going to assume we don't need any of
those and we'll give these modules names. The first one we'll call crawler and
we'll put it in a file called crawler.py. And the second one we'll call search,
and we'll put it in the file search.py. We're going to need to know something
more about these, and that's what the next quiz is going to get at.